>> Laura: THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A
GROWING PROBLEM WITH
ANTI-SEMITISM AND THE VOTERS CAN
TELL.
A NEW RASMUSSEN POLL FOUND 42%
OF LIKELY VOTERS THINK
ANTI-SEMITISM IS A GROWING
PROBLEM IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
35% DISAGREE.
AFTER THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
WATER DOWN THERE ANTI-SEMITISM
DECLARATION LAST WEEK TO PROTECT
CONGRESSWOMAN ILHAN OMAR, IT'S
NO WONDER AMERICANS BELIEVE THE
PARTIES HAVING A MAJOR BLIND
SPOT ON THIS ISSUE.
JOINING ME NOW, HARVARD LAW
PROFESSOR EMERITUS ALAN
DERSHOWITZ AND A MUSLIM
PROFESSOR AND REFORMIST.
PROFESSOR, THE MEDIA SEEM TO
CARE MORE ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S
CLAIM THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
ANTI-JEWISH RATHER THAN THE
GLARING EVIDENCE THAT THEY MIGHT
BE SO.
ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT THE
DIRECTION OF YOUR PARTY,
PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ?
>> I'M VERY WORRIED.
I DON'T THINK THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS ANTI-SEMITIC
BUT I'M AFRAID THAT THE CORE
ELEMENTS THAT TURN THE LABOUR
PARTY IN BRITAIN INTO A PARTY TA
PARTY IN BRITAIN INTO A PARTY TT
TOLERATES ANTI-SEMITISM COULD HP
TOLERATES ANTI-SEMITISM COULD HN
TOLERATES ANTI-SEMITISM COULD HT
TOLERATES ANTI-SEMITISM COULD HE
UNITED STATES.
THE PARTY IS NOT ANTI-SEMITIC
BUT THEY REFUSE TO CONFRONT THE
ANTI-SEMITISM OF A FEW
EXTREMISTS ON THE LEFT.
FOR EXAMPLE, ONE BLACK LIVES
MATTER STARTED, SOME PEOPLE SAID
WHY BLACK LIVES MATTER.
ALL LIVES MATTER.
PEOPLE WERE ACCUSED OF RACISM
FOR SAYING THAT.
IF IT'S ABOUT BLACK LIVES
BECAUSE BLACKS ARE BEING
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST, WE HAVE
TO SAY ONLY BLACK LIVES MATTER.
WE CAN'T SAY ALL LIVES MATTER
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO JEWS AND
THE ANTI-SEMITISM, YOU CAN'T SAY
ANTI-SEMITISM IS BAD.
YOU HAVE TO SAY ALL ISMS ARE
BAD.
>> Laura: THIS IS ALSO A
CONGRESSWOMAN, SITTING
CONGRESSWOMAN.
IT WASN'T JUST SOME GROUPS ARE
MORE PROTESTING.
I WANT TO GET YOU BECAUSE AS A
REFORMER, A MUSLIM REFORMER, YOU
TAKE ISSUE WITH THIS DIRECTION
OF A LOT OF THESE NEWBIE
CONGRESSWOMEN AND THEIR COHORT.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING FROM
ANOTHER PROMINENT NEWCOMER WHICH
IS RASHIDA TLAIB AND WHAT SHE
SAID ABOUT JOE GROWING
ISLAMAPHOBIA.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK YOUR OWN
PARTY REACTED SO STRONGLY
AGAINST WHAT HE SAID.
SPEAK I'M TRYING TO FIGURE IT
OUT.
THIS PAST WEEK, I FEEL AND I
KNOW THIS WOULD BE SOMEWHAT
SHOCKING FOR SOME, BUT I THINK
ISLAMAPHOBIA IS VERY MUCH AMONG
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS WELL AS
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> SO YOU THINK DEMOCRATS HAVE
SOME ISLAMAPHOBIA?
>> I THINK OUR COUNTRY IS
STRUGGLING WITH IT.
>> Laura: YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> WITH THE COUNTRY IS
STRUGGLING WITH IS A PERSON LIKE
ILHAN OMAR WHO WAS PROVEN
HERSELF TO BE BLATANTLY
ANTI-SEMITIC.
SHE IS A DISGRACE TO THE
UNITED STATES.
SHE IS A LIABILITY FOR THE
DEMOCRATS AND SHE'S AN
EMBARRASSMENT FOR MUSLIMS.
AND THEN WHEN SHE IS CAUGHT OUT
TIME AND AGAIN MAKING HORRIFIC
ANTI-SEMITIC REMARKS, SHE FALLS
BACK ON THE VICTIM IDEOLOGY
WHICH IS THE ISLAMAPHOBIA CARD
THAT HAS PLAYED SO WELL BY
ISLAMISTS ALL OVER THE WORLD.
I AM SURPRISED THAT THE
DEMOCRATS CAN'T SEE THE THROUGH
THAT.
THE VICTIM CARD IS I'M THE ONE
BEING STIGMATIZED.
RATHER, SHE HAS HELD BACK NO
WORDS IN HER HATRED FOR JEWS AND
FOR ISRAEL.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY APPALLING.
I'M A MUSLIM WOMAN.
I WANT TO DISTANCE MYSELF FROM
ILHAN OMAR AND RASHIDA TLAIB,
ALTHOUGH IT WOULD'VE BEEN SO
EXCITING FOR THE FIRST TWO
MUSLIM CONGRESSWOMAN TO HAVE
BEEN ELECTED BUT WHAT COMES OUT
OF THEIR MOUTHS IS APPALLING AND
VILE AND FULL OF HATE.
>> Laura: IT SO INTERESTING.
PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ, I'M SO
INTO THE MUSLIM REFORM MOVEMENT
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS SO NEEDED
AND IT'S SO REFRESHING.
I HAD AN INCREDIBLE GUEST ON
FRIDAY, FORMER
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" REPORTER
HAS BEEN FOCUSING ON LINDA
SARSOUR AND HER RADICALIZATION.
NOW WE HEAR FROM RAHEEL AND
THERE'S MANY LIKE THEM BUT THEY
DON'T -- I'M GOING TO GIVE THEM
A PLATFORM ON THE SHOW.
I THINK IT'S AWESOME.
RAHEEL, I THINK YOU'RE AWESOME.
I'M SO GLAD YOU CAME ON TONIGHT.
HONESTLY.
I HAVE HAIR UP ON MY ARMS
BECAUSE IT'S SO EXCITING.
>> THE BEST PROOF THAT WE DON'T
STOP SUFFER FROM ISLAMAPHOBIA IS
THAT WE WELCOME REFORMIST
MUSLIMS.
WANT TO HEAR FROM THEM.
WHAT WE ARE OPPOSED TO AS
AMERICANS ARE TERRORISM IN THE
NAME OF RELIGION NO MATTER WHO
THE TERRORISTS ARE, WHETHER THEY
ARE CHRISTIAN FUNDAMENTALISTS
WHO WANT TO BLOW UP ON ABORTION
CLINIC OR MUSLIM TERRORISTS WHO
WANT TO KILL JEWS.
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO THE
EXTREMISTS ON THE TERRACE.
WE ARE NOT OPPOSED TO ISLAM AND
THE BEST EVIDENCE OF THAT IS WE
WILL WELCOME MUSLIM REFORMERS.
THEY ARE WONDERFUL.
THEY CONTRIBUTE SO MUCH IN
AMERICA.
I WAS SO THRILLED WHEN I HEARD
THE TWO MUSLIM WOMEN WERE
ELECTED TO CONGRESS FOR THE
FIRST TIME, AND THEN WHEN THEY
STARTED THEIR HATRED, IT BECAME
VERY DIFFICULT BECAUSE
THEY WILL MAKE IT HARDER.
>> Laura: RAHEEL.
PEOPLE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
REALLY GOING ON, AND YOU HAVE
MADE A POINT THE PART OF WHAT
THEY ARE DOING IS NUMBING THE
PUBLIC TO ANY DIFFERENCES IN
MUSLIM IDEOLOGY AND THOUGHT.
>> THIS IS A PLOY OF THE
ISLAMISTS SINCE A LONG TIME, TO
COLLATE ANTI-SEMITISM AND
ISLAMAPHOBIA WHICH ARE TWO
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT THINGS.
WE KNOW ANTI-SEMITISM IS
INSTITUTIONALIZED HATRED OF
JEWS.
IT'S GENOCIDAL.
AND ILHAN OMAR CAN'T SAY SHE
DIDN'T KNOW.
SHE'S NOT NAIVE.
SHE GOT ELECTED TO CONGRESS.
SHE'S IN A POSITION OF POWER AND
SHE HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO
SPEAK OUT AND SUPPORT THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY THAT IS FACING SUCH
APPALLING PUSHBACK ALL OVER THE
WORLD, ESPECIALLY IN EUROPE.
HERE I AM.
WE SUPPORT.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, I AGREE,
THEY HAVE THEIR HEAD STUCK IN
THE SAND.
>> Laura: WE ARE ALMOST OUT OF
TIME.
ALLEN, QUICKLY.
WHAT DOES THE DEMOCRAT PARTY DO
HERE.
IF WHAT RAHEEL IS SAYING IS
TRUE, THEY'VE GOT A BIG PROBLEM
ON THEIR HANDS.
>> THEY DO AND THEY HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THEY DON'T BECOME THE
LABOUR PARTY BECAUSE THE LABOUR
PARTY IS LOSING GOOD AND DECENT
PEOPLE IN ENGLAND BECAUSE OF
CORBIN.
YOU CAN'T LET As TREMENDOUS    E
YOU CAN'T LET As TREMENDOUS    T
YOU CAN'T LET As TREMENDOUS    I
YOU CAN'T LET As TREMENDOUS    S
YOU CAN'T LET As TREMENDOUS    C
YOU CAN'T LET As TREMENDOUS    N
YOU CAN'T LET As TREMENDOUS    R